yeah so I I'm gonna talk about machine
learning today and okay cool so yeah I'm
gonna talk about machine learning and as
a fun case study I've turned on these
little captions that Google slides will
do for you just in case anybody has some
sort of auditory impairment hopefully
you can see those and if not then I'm
really apologize so my first question
for you today is have you ever applied
for a credit card I know I have a few
months ago I went online and was trying
to trying to get a credit card and it
had this form where I had to enter a
bunch of really personal information and
then at some point I clicked the button
that said submit and the page loaded and
while that page loaded apparently they
were able to make a decision because it
told me whether or not I got this card
immediately and it's kind of blew my
mind because first of all it's crazy
that they were able to make this
decision so quickly and second of all
like I was signing up at 2:00 a.m.
because apparently my idea of a good
time like all my friends are out
clubbing right because I guess that's
what cool people do but I was home like
trying to churn credit card rewards
because that's my idea of a good time so
it's 2:00 a.m.
why are think there can't be humans
sitting here grading these things and
even if there were how could they do it
so quickly and the secret here lies in
machine learning in other words they're
able to use past information to
determine whether or not I was a good
candidate for this credit card that's
kind of what we're gonna be talking
about today before I get into all of
that I work for a company called indeed
my name is Samuel Taylor in every single
indeed presentation I think you're
legally required to have this slide that
says we help people get jobs if you are
interested in helping people get jobs
please come talk to me afterward we love
data stuff and we love talking to data
people there are many things that this
talk is and that it aspires to be chief
among them is to introduce people to
machine learning so if you aren't
familiar with it you are in exactly the
right place and I'm so glad that you're
here it aims to be very friendly to
people who are new to this so even if
you're familiar with programming and
data and stuff and if you have no idea
what machine learning is
you will be fine here don't worry about
it at the same time I hope that this is
in some way helpful to people who have
more experience I always find it
enjoyable to see what other people have
worked on and try to understand the
problems that they ran into and so I
hope that in that way if you do have a
little bit more experience this will be
helpful for you the talk focuses on
application because I have found it more
interesting to hear about applications
of machine learning than to hear about
the theory over and over again at the
same time I try to respect the theory
that's button that underlies all these
things because it is really really well
thought through there's been a lot of
research into it and it can make us
better practitioners a lot of things
that this talk isn't the gist is it's
not a it's not a comprehensive tutorial
today like we hope you only have 45
minutes maybe 40 who knows so if there's
other things that you want to talk about
I'm happy to chat with you afterward but
we're just gonna go with a sort of
overview today this is the way we're
gonna be doing that well first talk
about just what even is machine learning
and then the bulk of the talk is gonna
be these use cases where in each one
we're gonna learn something new about
machine learning and about what happens
when we try to do that in the real world
let's start by talking about what
machine learning even is so for those of
you gathered in the audience today if
you've ever heard the phrase machine
learning before can I get you to raise
in hand okay there's some of you who are
lying because I've already said it today
and I'm gonna keep an eye on you because
I can tell I I know that I know which
ones are you are crafty okay for those
of you who are who prove just raise your
hand that's great if you have used
machine learning definitely like in
production but even if it's just like a
cool project that you did on the weekend
or something that you thought was really
interesting could you also raise a hand
okay cool awesome glad you're here for
those of you who didn't raise your hand
for that I'm so glad you're here and
there's gonna be a lot of learning so
those of you who did raise your hands
hopefully there's some new stuff in here
for you too
when I first waded into this world it
felt like I was trying to ride the
subway in a foreign city and I would ask
for directions and people would say oh
well obviously you just do this and this
and this and it felt like someone was
saying we'll just take the purple line
to the yellow line and then get off at
this stuff I don't know what these
things are or what
since I should be going how could I
possibly know this so to try to make
this a little bit more concrete and not
so scary people will break down machine
learning into a bunch of different areas
and that's what I've drawn up here on
the board today there are a bunch of
different things that we could talk
about this is the way that a lot of
people find useful to break things down
into so there's supervised machine
learning unsupervised machine learning
then there's a whole lot of other stuff
today we're mostly gonna be talking
about supervised learning and this
primarily breaks down into
classification problems and regression
problems in classification problems we
have some input data and some output
data here the input data is yellow so we
have someone's age and their net worth
and then the output data is in purple or
pink I guess depending on if I'm
colorblind and what we see here is we're
trying to predict from this input data
what is the value for the output data
here we could draw this on a graph and
look at it this way it's just a
convenient way to look at it and what
we're doing when we're trying to do
machine learning for all of the hype and
excitement and seemingly magical claims
that people make about machine learning
the real thing that happens is we just
draw a line like that's the whole magic
is we just figure out a really good way
to draw lines and that solves a lot of
problems as it turns out so machine
learning is kind of this project to get
really good at drawing lines and
sometimes these lines are a little
squiggly but there's the lines you know
and so what we could do is after we draw
this line then ask a question about okay
this new person comes in they are this
old they have this net worth should we
give them a credit card so that's that's
an example that sort of harkens back to
this intro idea of should we give person
a credit card and this is a way we could
teach a computer to do that as an aside
this is obviously just like a fake
example that I drew in particular you
might notice this very rich 12 and a
half year old who has like $500,000
that's a one percenter right there
anyway so then because this point that
we're asking about is above this line we
can now say yeah we would probably give
this person a credit card regression is
another kind of supervised learning
problem where we still have inputs and
outputs in this case I've drawn the
graph a little bit differently we have
our input along the x-axis and that's
the network
so given somebody's net worth how big of
a credit limit do we want to give them
and maybe we want to give people with a
large net worth more credit because we
think they're more likely to pay it back
and we could look at this data that we
have in the past say you know we did
have a bunch of humans in the room and
they did see you know they did actually
do these reviews of people and did make
a good decision about what size of loan
they were going to give someone and
that's the data that we have drawn up
here and then for all the hype and all
the magic you just draw another line so
that's kind of what machine learning is
and that's great and that's awful and
that's just what it is so then what
happens is after we've learned this
model when a new customer comes in we
can put wherever they are on the input
data in this case on the x-axis we can
say this new customer coming in has a
$500,000 networks we can jog up to the
line we drew and then jog over the
y-axis and say we're going to give this
customer a sixty thousand dollar line of
credit so those are both examples of
supervised learning let's now talk about
unsupervised learning so the main
algorithm that I think is interesting or
good to know when we talk about
unsupervised learning is clustering and
what's kind of interesting in
unsupervised applications is we want to
know we want to know something about the
data but we're not sure what so here we
might have these nine data points these
nine different shapes and they have a
different number of sides and they have
different colors and we might tell the
computer hey can you turn these data
points I have into three different
groups and the computer can say yeah
totally here's a group like I grouped
them by color and you're like thank you
computer that's great but there's no
reason the computer couldn't have given
you back these groups instead grouped by
shape so clustering is a way that we try
to find some underlying structure in the
data without having an explicit output
whereas in supervised learning we had
either a number or we had a like we had
it we had how much credit did we don't
wanna give somebody that's a good
example of a number or we have a sort of
binary yes/no decision and that's Lieut
an example of classification whereas in
clustering we don't have that we just
have data and we want to get some
structure out of it there's a lot of
other stuff that is machine learning
this kind of looks like it's a you know
a PowerPoint slide in secret it's
actually an
insurance policy against people yelling
at me on Twitter so if your favorite
algorithm is not covered it is it's
right here on this slide
to summarize machine learning uses data
to come up with some approximation for a
function that we care about the goal of
machine learning the thing we really
want to do is find this f of X this
function this magical function that
takes input and produces the exact
output so we could take in the past
stock prices and predict the future
that'd be amazing
there'll be the coolest thing ever we
can make so much money but the problem
is that we don't know what happens in
those situations we don't know how this
function works the stock market is very
crazy and there's a lot of factors that
go into there's so many different
players in it there are so many
different factors that come into this
that it might even not be possible to
know what moves the stock market the
nice thing is that we can measure points
drawn from this f of X we can look at
past examples from history and say we
see that when this happens then this
next thing is likely to happen so when
someone releases that they miss their
quarterly earnings the stock will
probably go down something like that the
problem is there's some noise in there
but it can give us hope that we do have
some information some signal in there as
well
so to summarize the way that I think
about machine learning is it is a set of
algorithms in which we try to find some
function G of X that approximates f of X
reasonably well let us now begin with
our first use case of the day all of
these use cases are going to go through
these five questions the first question
there's gonna be what is the problem in
this case the question is should we the
bank give this consumer a credit card so
a consumer comes to us and we want to
know whether we should give them a
credit card the data looks something
like this this is the same data I showed
you before I just figured out how to use
Google slides better and made a prettier
table so we have some data we have age
and net worth and then we know whether
or not this person was given credit
here's my favorite part and it will soon
be your favorite part of each of these
these cases is the question what kind of
machine learning problem is this so this
is the audience participation part it
does this sound like a classification
problem a regression problem a
clustering problem something else shout
at me get your anger classifications
anybody disagree anybody think it's
something
classification seen some headshake yes
y'all are very astute great work yes
this is a classification problem the
solution here we are at a PI data
conference the solution is Python and
scikit-learn it's gonna be great and
it's surprisingly simple to do something
like this we can import this linear
classifier from scikit-learn and then
set up our data I have it drawn up here
in that same graph that we had earlier
just to represent this data here is just
trying to represent the stuff we add on
the graph we can instantiate the
classifier object call fit and fit is
that step where we draw the line in the
first place so by calling fit we come up
with some line that separates these two
classes and then when a new person comes
in who is 63 years old and has $500,000
we can figure out whether or not the
model says we should give them credit by
calling this predict method and that's
where I have this question mark that new
person came in and the model output
whether or not we should give them
credit and in this case we should when I
do this my first question is is this
good like should I use this model how
accurate is it like can I use this and
this is where we get into some tricky
things with machine learning about
measuring error this is not a trick
question who thinks that model a this
this blue line that I have that sloping
down into the right who thinks that
model a is doing a better job at
approximating these points than model B
does anybody think okay good I warned
you it was a trick question yeah model B
is definitely better if we look at this
true function this this actual f of X
which is this green line that I drew we
can see that the blue line on the right
is a lot closer to that line than model
a is and that's easy for us to see as
human beings we can see oh these lines
are pretty close to each other that's
good but we have two things confounding
us here first of all in real life we
don't know where the Green Line is we
don't know the true function that
underlies all of this the second thing
that's tricky is that we have to come up
with some way of quantifying the amount
of error here we can look at these lines
and say they're close but how do we tell
a computer to figure out how close two
lines are the basic thing that we should
do here is to
randomly split our data up into training
data and testing data and there is the
gist here is that if we had a bunch of
data we could randomly say 20% of it
let's not look at it let's train the
model on the other 80% and then we can
evaluate it on the testing data so
there's a again a great scikit-learn MA
method called train test split that you
can use to do this and then we can train
a model so what I did here let me
explain me is this graph a little bit
what I did here was took the data that's
on the Left trained a model on it and
then the sort of regions that are
colored in are the predictions from the
model so the model thinks that this blue
region is the area where all the blue
points live and it's wrong in some cases
like it doesn't realize that there's
some there should be some blue points up
here even in the training data it wasn't
able to perfectly get this function
correct and there's a little orange
point over here that it also did not
correctly identify and that will happen
but the interesting thing here is that
because we set the testing data aside
and because we separated it completely
at random we can now take the same
colored regions overlay them on our
graph of the testing data and then count
up how many areas it makes so we see in
this case it makes two errors out of 20
points and so we might think that okay
in the real world when we're doing this
because on our testing data it made 2
out of 20 errors we might think that our
model is going to be wrong in 10% of the
cases and that's a way we can get a
sense for how good our model is ideally
at this point what you would do is
calculate the actual cost of something
bad going wrong now what I mean by that
is if we were trying to build a system
that took in radar data and tried to
determine whether a nuclear warhead was
coming at the US and we're wrong like
there's not actually a nuclear warhead
everyone's gonna die because we're gonna
shoot our nukes and then everyone's
gonna shoot Nixon ever was gonna die and
it's gonna be the destruction of the
human race it's the worst thing that we
can imagine happening right and the same
goes for if we're heads actually coming
to us and we don't see it like there's
no chance for us to shoot it down a
bunch of people die it's really bad so
there's real world cause costs there but
not every problem is like this think
about me fingerprinting into my phone if
somebody if like I'm trying to get into
my phone and it does it rejects my
fingerprint and
I get a little bit annoyed but I just
tap it again and then it realizes it on
this second chance and so rejecting me
that first time was fine like it's a
little bit annoying but it's a lot
better than somebody who's not me being
able to get into my phone so if that
happens someone's able to fingerprint it
to my phone they can look through my
memes and tell me that they're not funny
and that's gonna hurt my feelings deeply
I'm gonna have to go get some therapy
after that and that's like I really like
those people are expensive is like $80
an hour so it's there's a lot bigger
cost they're associated so ideally what
we could see is in our testing data we
made this kind of area this often and
that kind of error results in $80 of
therapy time whereas the other error
results in like 50 cents of advance and
you can multiply those numbers together
add them all up and see how good your
model is actually doing in the real
world it's not always possible to do
that unfortunately so what we have to do
is come up with different error metrics
that kind of get us close to that or get
us some way of comparing models to each
other for regression problems the common
one is called mean squared error I have
an example here where we might have some
true values that we know that we split
out as part of our testing data and then
some values that I have drawn in green
and with a little extra outline there in
case you are colorblind though I don't
know if you can tell as much up on the
screen but hopefully the ones with a
stronger outline are the ones that are
predicted values and what you can do is
subtract those numbers from each other
and then square those and take the
average so then you can add up to this
last column here divided by 4 and say
the average mean squared error was 18
point 3 5 for this model and that gives
you some sense for how good or bad this
model is that you can use to compare to
other models that you might have another
kind of error that you might or another
another thing that people often use is
classification error which is when you
have some when you have some
classification problem you can just look
at how many areas you're making and so
in this case we see that we make one
error we accidentally classify a point
that is truly orange as blue and that
means that we have roughly a 25%
classification error so these are
metrics that we can use to quantify how
good our models are so at the end of
each use case we'll talk about some
lessons that we learned first thing is
that it's pretty neat it's just math and
computers are able to figure this stuff
out and you
actually have to be a linear algebra
genius to use this stuff and to get
value from it another thing that we
learned was very important is to have
testing data so that way we can evaluate
our models let's now move on to our next
use case in which we will teach a
computer sign language so we'll start
again like all the use cases with what
is the problem problem is I don't know
sign language but there's a lot of deaf
people that I would love to communicate
with because they have valuable things
to communicate and I think that's messed
up that I just I can't communicate with
them so I found this little device that
you can plug into your laptop and it has
a little like infrared camera and
infrared LEDs and stuff in there and in
real life you can't see this little like
you can't see this little violet thing
that's coming out of here but that's an
IR LED I don't know about photography I
don't know why you can see it in the
picture but anyway it shines IR on your
hand and as you're moving around your
hand it can sort of track where your
individual joints are something like
this so in this example someone has the
device on their desk and they're holding
up their hands something like this and
the computer is able to turn that into
this three-dimensional data so the data
itself looks like this we have 20
different points on the human hand and
it gives us x y and z coordinates for
all 20 of those and most of those are
joints but there's one in the middle of
the middle of your palm and I think
there's one at the wrists or something
so what what my friend and I did was we
took this device and we were at a
hackathon and we decided let's try to do
something to solve this sign-language
problem so we plugged a thing into our
laptop and we said we looked up the ASL
alphabet and we're like let's just try
the alphabet first so plug it in and
we're like ok I was making a above the
sensor and like move it around and tell
it hey this is an A and just repeatedly
told it an A and then made a B above the
sensor and hit B a bunch of times and
eventually we have this data set that
you see on the screen where we have some
points for each joint we have XY and Z
points and then we have a number of
signs that we can try to predict so our
inputs are going to be these 60 points
these 60 data points and their output is
going to be what sign is the person
making a through Z here's the best part
what kind of machine learning problem is
this
okay clustering is anybody think is
anything different from clustering
someone thing is classification okay
anybody think is anything other than
clustering or classification okay so it
is a common actually when I've given
this talk before sometimes people think
this is clustering it's not actually in
this case and the reason is that in
clustering we don't know what we want to
predict but in classification we do so
in this case we do know that we want to
predict an A through Z and and in this
case we so because you have 26 different
things that you're trying to predict
you're trying to predict it's a member
of one of these 26 classes it is a
classification problem so yeah it's a
classification problem but not uncommon
to think is clustering and clustering
you could you can do clustering on this
it just wouldn't be this exact problem
that we were trying to solve you might
learn something else by doing clustering
so when we go into the solution part
here the first thing that we did was try
to choose a model we had this data and
we were trying to think what model is
going to work well in it so just like
we've already learned it's a good idea
to split your data up into training data
and testing data and then we just like
imported every model we could from psych
Atlanta and we said let's just try a
bunch of these things and evaluate them
on the test data let's just train them
and then run through and see which one
does best this actually is not the worst
thing you could do it's not like the
greatest thing ever also but like it's
as long as you're not doing this
repeatedly over and over again and you
could probably be okay doing this you
can run a risk if you do this over and
over again you end up picking a model
that just does really well in your
training data but your real-world data
might not look like your training data
unfortunate or not might not look like
your testing data unfortunately but this
is not a bad first approach at this and
so then we thought okay cool we got this
amazing model this is great let's build
an application the first thing we
thought was let's make a keyboard let's
make it to where you can type in you
know letters a B whatever and it will
turn that into some text on a screen
that you could use to type back and
forth not that like people can't type
but we just thought it was an
interesting idea turned out this did not
work very well we were having a
difficult time figuring out like when
are people changing the sign that
they're making and so we're like well
let's just scrap that entirely and come
up with something else so we figured out
that our model was still good enough
that we can make a little educational
game kind of like a rosetta stone for
sign language thing
and this is a little let's see if this
YouTube video wants to load there's no
sound on this or anything but the it
shows you a little image of a letter and
says hey make this sign this is an a
this is a B whatever and then as you get
it correct it will give you points and
at the end you get to type your name in
as a little like leaderboard because I
guess everyone loves leaderboards anyway
I'm not very good at this game but the
so this is just a little demo to get
give you an idea of what you can kind of
do with this stuff so there are some
things that we learned in this process
and surprisingly a large amount of
things that I learned from this that are
applicable today in my real-world life
that I didn't think I was going to learn
from just this sort of 24-hour toy
hackathon thing the first thing is that
defining the problem is really important
and really challenging being able to
figure out from this sensor like what
can I even what data can I even gather
from it what is something that I find
interesting kind of coming up with the
intersection of that and then coming up
with okay what if we did sign language
okay well actual sign language has its
own grammar and its own rules and
there's a lot of their signs that move
for instance and so you can't do
something just based on it's not there's
so many so much complexity of this but
being able to come up with some problem
that you can concretely solve and
casting it as a machine learning problem
is very difficult and I think really
important to be able to do the thing
that enabled us to do get make any
progress was to limit scope again I
thought this was something we were just
doing because we had a 24-hour hackathon
in real life this ends up being super
important to when you have a problem
that is large oftentimes the best way to
solve it is to break it up into smaller
problems and then solve those
individually so in this case we said
sign language is is cool and then we're
here maybe just American Sign Language
maybe just the alphabet which isn't
super useful but gets you a start at
understanding what the kinds of problems
that you run into are we talked a little
bit about model selection here and this
for one exposed me to the problem of
model selection and how to figure out
what model to use and got me familiar
with at least one method of doing that
the another really important sort of
lesson that I learned was that it's more
just the model you have you might have a
model that will make you a garbage
keyboard that doesn't work very well at
all but the model could still have value
in being used for this rosetta stone
desk application which is interesting if
you're if you're working in a corporate
context this is a great place to sit
with the product people and sit with
your customers and try to understand
what are their pain points and what are
things that I can solve with machine
learning to make their workload lighter
or more efficient or whatever move now
to forecasting energy load so the
problem here is that we have to know
when to schedule energy production
imagine that we are an electricity grid
and we need to know when to want to make
our power plants start generating
electricity because I'm not an engineer
like batteries aren't good I guess since
you have to schedule your energy
production close to when it's going to
be used I think this isn't entirely this
is not entirely hypothetical so for any
of you who are here from out of town
there's this thing in Texas called
arkhat which is the energy reliability
Council of Texas and everywhere except
well most places except notably Austin
have this deregulated energy market
where people can buy energy from whoever
they want and I think what ends up
happening is those providers turn back
around and buy it from ERCOT or
something I don't know again there's a
lot of things I don't know but this is a
problem that you that someone has and
they have to figure out how to solve it
and you can see that they divide up the
state into these different weather zones
because as it turns out energy usage
course correlates highly with Corley's
highly with weather so the data kind of
looks like this we have some time some
time of the day in the hour
the date in the hour and then the output
we have actually like nine different
outputs here and you can download these
Express Excel spreadsheets from Orkut
themselves and they'll say hey this is
how much power was used across the state
or in each of these weather zones during
this hour so the input here we have is
the time of day and the output is the
energy load being used in terms of
kilowatt hours I thought it was fun to
put this on a little graph so I did that
and even at this point I think it's kind
of interesting to look and see well and
you know in the summer things get a lot
heavier usage because you know it gets
hot here
don't like that so even here I think
it's interesting but we could apply
machine learning to this right so what
if we wanted to predict how much energy
usage was happening and what kind of
machine learning problem is this okay
regression does anyone think is anything
other than regression someone things
clustering anybody think anything other
than clustering okay it is regression in
this case it's a good good call so and
the reason that it is regression and not
clustering again is because with
clustering we don't know the output
we're not we're not sure what we're
trying to output in regression we know
that we're trying to predict the number
of the the amount of energy being used
so there's a strict number that we're
trying to predict and the reason that
it's not clustering is because
clustering would be predicting like a
distinct number of things whereas with
regression we're trying to pick a
continuous value so there's a number of
things we need to know here with
regression the first is that when we're
dealing with time series data it often
exhibits seasonality this is a graph of
weekly energy load in a crop across the
state of Texas and you can see that
there's big bumps in the summer and then
sometimes you get these little bumps in
the winter if it's a particularly cold
winter people are going to run their
heaters but that doesn't happen super
often here and what's tricky is this
thing that I told you was a good idea at
the start of the talk which is to
randomly split your data up into
training data and testing data is not a
good idea when you have time series data
and the reason that is is because if you
were to do that and have the AR blue
data be the training data and our orange
data be the testing data we're gonna
leak some information so if we look at
this particular part of the graph
there's an orange point in there that is
a testing data point and it is
surrounded on both sides by blue points
which means that those are points we
know about which means that if we are
trying to test our model and say hey
what would the energy usage be right
here the model can look ahead to the
future maybe like well the day after
that it's this so I'm gonna say it's a
little bit less than that and in real
life you don't know that you don't know
the future when you're making these
predictions so what you what you should
do when you have time series data is do
a split that's based on time because
that more accurately reflects the way
that this model will end up getting used
the way that you will have information
in production so this is an example of
sort of six different splits that you
could make starting with it starting
with you know a little chunk and then
adding on some extra base like we've
been taking a little extra in the future
and saying let's make our model predict
for this now you can do this a bunch of
times and get a bunch of different
splits between training data and testing
data and test your model in each of
those cases now another tricky thing
about time series data is that some
models are not very good at it so this
is a model I trained and it just like
completely doesn't miss it doesn't
realize that it can do tricky things
like this and that is not great so it's
a good idea to do something a little bit
more more intense and there's a lot of
people who do a lot of research on how
to model time series problems and I
would highly recommend using this
library called profit because it will
take a bunch of that research into
account and make models that are a lot
smarter than than some others so the
main thing that we learned here is that
time series data is really special and
you should think about it very carefully
because it has seasonality don't use a
random split of your training data in
your testing data the last thing we will
talk about today is using machine
learning to find our next job so the
problem here is passive job hunting and
this is a couple years ago at this point
I was reasonably happy in my job but I
was kind of like you know maybe
something coolers out there and I
thought well this would be a fun little
side project to do of gathering up a
bunch of jobs and then figuring out
which ones sound cool and maybe I could
like make a robot email me the coolest
jobs that sounds interesting and so I
made this thing this little spreadsheet
where I would go and enter in a bunch of
jobs and I'd put a link to the job
description and then when I was bored
like I was in line at the you know or
like waiting for the bus or like waiting
first you know I had like Subway
sandwiches or something I'd pull up the
thing I click on the Job Description I
would go read it I'll come back to the
spreadsheet and I would say whether or
not that job sounded cool now I will
admit to you just just right now no
judgment hopefully that I spent way
longer doing this than I would have
spent like actually just using a normal
like job search procedure but given that
all of you are at a software conference
on a Saturday I think this is a safe
place for me to admit my
over-engineering tendencies so here we
are at a park west of what kind of
machine learning problem is this we have
some information about a job and we're
trying to predict whether or not it
would sound cool to me
I'm hearing classification does anybody
think anything other okay yes this is a
classification problem
the tricky thing here is we've seen how
we've seen data before where we're
dealing with numbers and we're trying to
say from this number and this number
let's break this value but we have it a
job title now and a job title isn't a
number so it's like what do we even do
here right like how do we turn a job
title into the number five like what
does that even mean how would we do that
so I did what I highly recommend you do
when you run into problems is Google
just like how do I do this thing and so
I googled like text representations
machine learning and this is the first
thing it came up it is not a new idea
and but it's a good place to start so
what you do is you take your all of your
documents all of your job pedals and put
them on the rows of a matrix and then
make columns for every unique word in
the data set so for instance for this
first one we see that the word engineer
does not occur in the job title so we
say zero but the word web does so we
have we put a 1 in that column and etc
etc I'm not gonna go through that the
the tedium of filling this out for you
because that sounds boring one thing I
do want to make sure you note is that in
this model of text if you have a
repeated word you can have multiple
things so if someone posted a job called
data data data data first of all like
I'm interested in hearing about it
second of all you would get a four in
the the data column there and what we
call this is either word count vectors
or a vector space model of language so
now we're able to take a job title and
turn it into this word count vector and
we can take our sounds cool in Dakota as
a one if it sounds cool or zero if it
doesn't now we have numbers and we can
plug it in to scikit-learn again and the
code look is actually relatively simple
to do this you can take these job titles
take whether or not it sounded cool do
this count vectorizer thing which does
the work of turning these
titles into word count vectors and then
finally train a model on it so we call
fit and that's gonna do our work our
drawing this fancy line and then we can
call predict on the new jobs that we
have coming in and say do these sound
cool or not and they will end up
outputting this array that says these
ones didn't sound cool but that fourth
job did sound cool so I did this and I
got a classification error of 20% about
and I'm thinking this is great like I'm
barely even trying and I'm already
getting 80% accurate this is awesome and
then I dug in a little bit further and I
found out that the base rate was 0.197
which means that only 20% of the jobs I
ever found were cool and my model figure
out I'm just gonna say nothing is cool
and then I'm gonna get 80% right this is
great I'll get a B just for not doing
anything so I drew this self-portrait
after I did that the the thing you
should probably be doing is not just
relying on classification error because
it can trick you in interesting ways one
way that people use to combat this is to
use something called a confusion matrix
where you have the predicted values
along one axis of a matrix and then
along the other the actual values if I
had done this I would very easily be
able to see oh I'm just predicting zero
for everything and all my errors are
coming when there's actually these
interesting jobs and I would know well
that's the only thing I care about so
clearly my model isn't doing well enough
another set of error metrics you can use
when you have this sort of imbalance
situation is to use precision and recall
to put it succinctly precision is a way
of asking for all of the job titles that
I say are cool that my model says are
cool how many of them actually turn out
to be cool and then recall is a way of
saying of all of the job titles that I
know about that are actually cool how
many of them is my model saying are cool
so if I had done this if I had looked at
this I would see that my recall was zero
because I was not predicting that any
title sided cool so zero of the actually
cool and titles were coming back is cool
another useful technique for imbalanced
data is to do resampling of the data so
one thing you can do is take your that
does 80% of jobs that didn't sound cool
and just throw away a bunch of them
because you don't need them and you can
get it closer to a balanced scenario and
your model can
your model won't be incentivized to
cheat as much that way if you make it
balanced and it will realize like well I
have to actually try now is the idea so
I ended up doing under sampling and then
I made this little thing that would
email me once a week I've since turned
this off but it was a fun project
nobody emailed me once a week and say
hey B's job sounded cool this week I'm
go ahead and look at all right there's a
some things we learned the first thing
we learned is understand what the base
rate of your problem is try to figure
out if your model is being silly if it's
trying to be tricky with you you want to
know that you want to know what would
happen if I did the dumbest thing
imaginable I just predicted the most
common class in each case another thing
we learned is that a simple model isn't
necessarily ineffective I started this
wanting to like use some crazy like deep
learning stuff on text and then I did
logistic regression which is a very
simple model and realized this works
really well how great but I was also a
little bit sad on the inside and the
reason this works is because of a thing
called the approximation generalization
trade-off what that means is you can
choose between being able to do really
well at the training set or being able
to generalize better to data that you
haven't seen yet so give an example
that's more concrete imagine we have
these data points on the board that are
our training data and I have drawn the
the truth is this blue line and then I
have built two models a linear
regression model and a nearest-neighbor
model the nearest neighbor model is
incredible at approximating data it
actually has no errors from the train
data it is perfect at approximating the
linear regression model is not as good
as approximating there are places where
it's kind of far from some of the
training data but what's neat is when we
look at the testing data the linear
regression model despite its lack of
approximation does a lot better on
generalization so when we choose simple
models we often are able to generalize
better and that's one reason why we
should choose to use simple models at
first especially is because you get a
lot of generalization ability just by
using a simple model the other thing is
it's just easier like it's been a while
since I've tried to setup tensorflow or
PI tort or whatever on my laptop but it
is significantly harder than just pip
install SK learn so it's often easier to
do this and faster to train and you can
iterate a lot more quickly doing use
when you use simple models
okay I'll take a deep breath we've
talked about a lot of things some last
takeaways to sort of try to tie a bow on
this package supervised learning is a
set of techniques where we try to use
past examples to predict either a
continuous variable in the case of
regression or a discrete variable in the
case of classification you can measure
performance of these models by splitting
your data into training data and testing
data before you do the training the
another thing we learned is to keep it
simple because when we try the simplest
thing that could possibly work sometimes
it works and you don't have to try the
hard thing which is very nice when that
happens the last thing I would say is to
test out your models and iterate and you
are going to learn a lot more by trying
out something that you can do very
quickly like a little gistic regression
model and then figuring out what you
need to do next rather than going
through all the work of building some
really complicated data pipeline is a
really complicated model first because
using that simple model will then enable
you to do have much quicker feedback
loops which is really nice all right
that's the that's the stuff I have for
you today again I work it indeed and
they are really nice for letting me come
do this kind of thing if you're
interested in any of that please come
talk to me the slides are available at
this link here go to nba.com slash PDA
19 that's short for PI data Austin 19 I
think we need to get moving to the next
talk so we don't have time for questions
but if you do have questions feel free
to email me I would love to chat with
you the data stuff is one of my favorite
kinds of stuff so yeah just email me
we'd love to hear from you and thank you
for your time
[Applause]
awesome let's do that yeah I I don't
know much about energy consume
consumption but I would assume that it's
not only times his problem but also
whether contribute significantly on how
much energy expense yes I was wondering
what was the reason
yeah that's so that's that's a great
question um so the question yeah so
piano Mike I won't repeat it the the
main reason for this is actually just
for like pedagogical reasons it's easier
to just talk through like it's time and
the second thing is that you can
actually get a decent model by using
time because time and weather are so
correlated now you can definitely have
it be better by adding in weather data
because there's going to be places where
it's 80 degrees in December like that
just happens sometimes so yeah that's
the main reason is but yeah in real life
you would definitely want to use weather
in this case
yeah so one thing that I think is yeah
yeah because I keep tricking yon like
you think this is clustering no it's not
it's never trust rating so one thing
that I have seen be interesting in
clustering is if you think about like
let's use that that jobs dataset example
if we had some data set of jobs and
let's say we end up having like 9,000
unique words in that it might be
computationally intractable to have a
model that has 9,000 features and so one
thing that some people will do is
cluster those job titles and try to find
groups of job titles that are similar to
each other and then maybe you end up
with like 9 groups and then you can have
you know you could have like nine
features instead of 9,000 so some people
I have seen people use it as sort of
like a way of understanding the
underlying structure of the data and
then using that to kind of build a model
off of that instead of building it off
of the raw data for some reason yeah
another place I've seen it be used is if
you're trying to understand your
customer base for instance and you want
to know who's buying our product you can
gather a bunch of data about them and
then build some clustering over them and
and then analyze and then figure out
like oh these are small businesses these
are large businesses trying to hire
nurses things like that yeah and that
can help you do a lot of things yeah
thank you appreciate it all
[Applause]